this is just the best back when Donald
Trump tweeted about how stable and smart
he is and how he's not experiencing
cognitive decline I tweeted and also
mentioned on the show when you're the
President of the United States and
you're actively talking about and trying
to convince people that you're both
mentally stable and smart you've sort of
already lost and that's not a good thing
we have another example of where now
Donald Trump is insisting that he's not
racist okay here's a very short video of
after the entire [ __ ] hole country's
comment and a whole bunch of other stuff
here's Trump insisting he's just not
racist at all
and to see what the room said about my
comments that were made
I love that I'm the least racist person
that you've ever interviewed now it just
so happens the guy he pointed to mostly
interviews really racist people so Trump
being the least racist isn't is it
actually that meaningful anyway we have
a president who regularly has to try to
convince the world that he's not losing
his mind that he's not a racist and this
is the same Trump by the way who on the
one hand says he's not racist but he led
the charge that Obama was born in Kenya
and faked his birth certificate he got
in trouble in the past for not renting
apartments to black people in New York
City he said the Central Park five were
guilty which they weren't he said a
judge whose parents are Mexican needs to
resign because he can't possibly be a
fair on immigration cases he said that
some Nazi protesters in charlottesville
were very fine people and that Mexicans
coming to the United States are
criminals rapists and thugs although
some are probably good people as well
that's the guy who we have no reason
whatsoever to suspect might be a little
bit racist and it's such a trumpian
response to you can't just say I'm not a
racist you have to say I'm the least
racist person that you know yeah I don't
actually think by the way that Trump is
necessarily proactively racist I think
Trump is ignorant I think he grew up in
such privileged circumstances that a lot
of this stuff these stereotypes
he believes on the basis of ignorance
now that's not a defense right because
the impact of whatever policies Trump
would favor as a result of that
ignorance would still be disastrous and
so I have to criticize them but but that
I think that that's more what's going on
here and by the way even saying I'm I'm
not racist I'm the least racist person
anyone who lives in the world in a sort
of normal way harbors some race-related
stereotypes and stereotypes exist at
least in part because there's so many
people in the world right and we have a
desire to predict people's behavior to
make the world easier to understand so
you categorize people
you categorize people in an attempt to
better make sense of the world and to
predict what an interaction with a
particular person might be like if
someone has this characteristic it's
more likely that they might act in this
way or think that way or whatever now
it's not a great thing to do when it
causes a ton of problems but the idea of
saying I'm just not racist it also shows
Trump's totally disconnected sort of
from the realities of of being a human
on this planet and that's where you have
to be open to contradictory evidence
right the way we know behavioral
psychology works oftentimes when people
are presented with or they see
contradictory evidence they sometimes
become more ingrained in their beliefs
right when you see that Jewish person
who's not cheap you assume well that
person is the exception but as a general
my rule still works and to use Trump's
example about Mexicans being rapists and
criminals if you hear about a group of
Mexicans that has absolutely no
connection whatsoever to rape or
criminality they must be the exception
but generally speaking you've still got
to have your guard up the way Donald
Trump is suggesting so the entire I'm
not racist thing aside from just being
yet another embarrassment by Trump on
the international stage if you want to
talk about race relations and
stereotypes and prejudice and racism I'm
not racist as a sort of meaningless
non-starter it's completely unproductive
in every way yeah and what you just laid
out was exemplified by his announcement
that he was running for president when
he said that some Mexicans are good
people right but the vast majority of
them are rapists and criminals yes
providing that exception yes but it's
still not changing what the overall
immigration policy should be I guess
like his view of the immigration policy
should be the same although there's
probably exceptions to this rule
supposed to be that by the rule they're
good people and then there are
exceptions to that which are the bad
people like with any group that you
would imagine could could be categorized
so anyway another Trump embarrassment on
the national stage the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particular
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad